The Penguin features prominently in Matt Reeves's
"The Batman," but did you know that this famous
comics character has seen many different versions
portrayed over the years?
Stay tuned to get a look at how the Penguin
from "The Batman" should really look.
Warning: Spoilers ahead.
Batman has been adapted for the big screen
by numerous filmmakers, all of whom have interpreted
the character and his stories in unique ways.
Tim Burton embraced the pulpier element of
Gotham's caped crusader while adding his trademark
gothic-horror stylings to the proceedings
in 1989's "Batman" and its sequel, "Batman
Returns."
Joel Schumacher, meanwhile, leaned into the
campier side of the Dark Knight when he was
tasked with helming "Batman Forever" and "Batman
& Robin."
Elsewhere, Christopher Nolan opted for a more
grounded and realistic approach to crime-fighting
in the "Dark Knight" trilogy.
The latest iteration of the World's Greatest
Detective on screen comes from filmmaker Matt
Reeves, best known for his work on "Cloverfield"
and the most recent "Planet of the Apes" trilogy.
"The Batman" is a neo-noir thriller with horror
elements, boasting a story that focuses on
a psychologically damaged Bruce Wayne and
his alter-ego Batman, as he proclaims himself
to be vengeance incarnate.
"I'm Vengeance."
Naturally, "The Batman" also takes some creative
liberties with the source material and presents
familiar characters in fresh and interesting
ways.
The film's depiction of the Penguin, for instance,
is a huge departure from any other incarnations
of the villain on the screen.
But how is the character supposed to look?
The Penguin, otherwise known as Oswald Cobblepot,
has been one of the most popular villains
in the "Batman" canon for decades.
Known for his umbrellas, cigars, extravagant
tuxedo, and trademark waddle, the crime kingpin
has a recognizable look that just screams
villainy.
Over the years, he has been portrayed by the
likes of Burgess Meredith, Danny DeVito, and
Robin Lord Taylor, all of whom established
a firm image of the character in the pop-culture
imagination.
However, Colin Farrell's Penguin in "The Batman"
isn't the same menace who's graced previous
movies and TV shows.
For a start, the cigar, top hat, and tuxedo
are all gone in exchange for everyday gangster
clothing.
He does carry an umbrella at times, but it
doesn't possess the ability to fire bullets.
Farrell, who lobbied for a cigar, discussed
the changes in a December 2021 interview with
Empire.
The actor acknowledged the key alterations
made to the character, but he also wants fans
to know that it's still early in Cobblepot's
quest to become the familiar foe.
He revealed:
"Oz is not yet fully inhabiting the mythology
of the Penguin and doesn't take too kindly
to the [Penguin] moniker."
It remains to be seen how the Penguin will
evolve in the "Batman" franchise moving forward.
However, he will return to the fold in a substantial
way.
Warner Bros. has major plans for the character,
so fans can look forward to a more fleshed-out
story at a later date.
While he probably should have died in "The
Batman," the Penguin survived the chaos and
will live to fight another day in Gotham's
criminal underbelly.
Warner Bros. has ambitious plans for the character,
who is set to receive his own spin-off TV
series.
The story will reportedly chronicle Cobblepot's
rise from mid-level Gotham gangster into the
grandiose crime kingpin he's typically depicted
as in the movies, TV shows, and comics.
Details about the series are being kept close
to the vest right now, but early reports have
compared it to "Scarface," a mob saga that
follows one gangster's ascension in the criminal
underworld.
"Say hello to my little friend."
Of course, it's highly likely that some changes
will be made to the Penguin character in this
version of the DC franchise.
Most characters differ from their older counterparts
in some way, after all.
"The Batman" gives us a menacing serial killer
version of the Riddler, who wouldn't seem
out of place in a movie like "Se7en."
Then there's the Joker, who, despite being
hidden behind a cell door during his brief
cameo in the movie, doesn't appear to resemble
any previous versions of the character.
In short, it remains to be seen if the Penguin
will rock top hats and fire bullets from an
umbrella in the spin-off series and future
movies.
At the same time, the unpredictability is
exciting in its own right, and it'll be interesting
to see it all unfold.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.